willkommen zum letzten akt müssen fragen
die grünen sind ganz harmlos die roten
sind gemein
ich kann es selber wählen dann nehmen
sie roten grünen weil ich bei drei
greifen aufmachen reingreifen aufmachen
und die soll ich vor diesen beantworte
oder was tor lesen und beantworten
wir haben uns sehr viel mühe gegeben
kann man das nicht ohne mit klein machen
das stimmt das aber eigentlich müsste
das ich weiß gar nicht hier wird sowieso
jedes papier in köln wird an die
müllverbrennungsanlage geliefert die das
gar nicht leisten
das will ich nicht werden ja es ist das
altpapier in köln sammeln wir damit die
müllverbrennungsanlage funktioniert weil
sonst würde die nicht funktionieren also
die 14 frage die große volksfeste wie
können wir uns sicher sein dass du uns
nicht zu machen hält also die große
volksweise buch titel eines neuen buches
und wer sich das gefühl hat dass ich den
leser phase der muss es ja nicht lesen
kauft man freiwillig die frage die
dahinter steckt ist es eine masche oder
ist es dein innerstes interesse was für
die umwelt zu tun
in dem buch geht es weniger um geld als
um also ohne dies zu engagieren also das
buch habe ich gemacht weil ich mich
selber in diesem konsum schon nicht mehr
zurechtfindet ich lese dauern
die textilen darf nicht mehr kaufen das
darf sie nicht mehr essen das darf nicht
mehr und ich wollte mich einmal schlau
machen was tatsächlich noch konsumierbar
ist ohne dass man sich selber die
gesundheit oder belichtung arbeiter
irgendwo schädigt und die idee waren
konsumenten damit zu machen was für mich
funktioniert und vielleicht auch für
andere die beim konsumieren vor und
nachdenken dass dieses buch ist und
eigentlich war mein anspruch nicht
irgendjemand zusammenzuhalten okay gut
sehr schön du siehst gemeinde
unterstellung
so und auch du wirst lassen ich nehme
nur die unbequemen fragen im moment sich
in deutschland engagieren aber in den
staaten leben fehlt da nicht die
volksnähe
also muss ich zwei dinge zu sagen mein
hauptwohnsitz ist deutschland und den
usa für grünes licht zum schreiben weil
ich habe ihn nicht finden ich benehme
herr drehbuch unterschreibt mit einer
amerikanischen kundin und wenn ich nicht
schreibe bin ich in deutschland und ich
glaube ich bin präsent genug und arbeit
genug in deutschland mit deutschen
kollegen deutschen firmen deutschen
sendern um in etwa zu wissen was hier
los ist ich lese auch regelmäßig
deutsche medien also tages die deutsche
elite tage bisschen in deutschland eher
gut ist das problem sich sehr viele
deutsche produktion mein nächster
deutscher und dreht in thailand ich habe
jetzt eine deutsche produktion namibia
gedreht eine südafrika und eine malaysia
das problem sich auch dass wir deutschen
firma dahingehend billig drehen kann
insofern würde sagen ich bin etwa sechs
monate im jahr hier wie heftig das geht
so dass noch eine rose lieblingssong von
mir so unbequem finde ich die frage wir
haben wir wollen wir versuchen auch
immer die grenzen zu gehen dass der gast
noch da bleibt ich würde auch bleiben
wenn es eine riecht es bräuchte hierfür
den hab ich zähle ich nicht schlimm
allerdings dass auch das kann ich aber
puzzeln die kenne ich auch die frage von
daher kann ich ja das ist wohl sind
jetzt hier
ich kann daher die frage zerlegt haben
da muss noch was sein
ich weiß aber wie wasser heiß da fehlt
irgendwie total was hab ich kann dir
sagen du siehst volksschauspieler ist da
drin gewesen so als volksschauspieler
das den namen hört sich erstmal um die
ohren
und ganz ehrlich das habe ich gefunden
ich verleihe ich nicht überhaupt nicht
das heißt ja eigentlich nur dass man ein
relativ breites publikum ansprechen
natürlich es gibt sicherlich
schauspieler maria b
die machen wirklich nur kings coni
kinski notiere das freundin die finde
ich großartig
ich will mich auch gern machen aber ich
bin nummer im deutschen fernsehen tätig
und habe offensichtlich zuviel sommer
kommerzielle ware gedreht da sicherlich
auch nicht immer ein geistiger höhenflug
ist das weiß ich selber und oft auch
sehr entwickeln mäßig aber dadurch habe
ich ein relativ breites publikum
es gibt halt echt ins studio alter maßen
opas die nicht lustig finden ich habe
mein glück in einem hochsicherheitstrakt
in deutschland nämlich detail prüfen und
es gibt junge leute die mir schreiben zu
sein finde ich das wort ist erstmal
keine beleidigung okay und was wenn du
so drehbücher bekommst wo du denkst oh
gott das muss ich sagen
dann schreibe ich heiser und mache mich
damit auch echt nicht besonders keine
vorstellen gewissen produzenten bei
guten produzenten die erlauben dass und
das in absprache mit richtigen
produktion aber wenn der dialog satz
richtig gut ist und die hört man ja das
wird doch es gibt ja so produkts
schreibe ich dir warum oder streich sie
einfach irgendwas nicht sagen ja gut
aber dann könntest ja durch die ein oder
anderen produktion komplett ohne eine
äußerung gehen also ich einmal clint
eastwood interview gelesen hat als
erstes umtriebig die hälfte des nook
streichen
das mache ich manchmal okay gut dann
würde ich dir noch viele produktionen
wurde das nicht machen und da will dass
einige mal sogar voll ist okay vielen
dank ich habe zu dann super spaß
der überragende sagen